it is not possible
it is not possible to have both Dei and
Free Speech you either get Dei or you
get free speech anything else
you see you have a simple choice so
anybody making a Chicago statement or
this declaration it's just not true it's
Harvard put something up about that
reason they have it's never going to
work it's literally impossible because
the whole mission of Dei is to limit
what people say so they won't so certain
minorities won't be won't quote unquote
feel excluded the whole I the whole
premise of it is that that the system is
inherently racist
um everything from who gets into the
institutions and universities SAT scores
the whole it's just not possible